this is joe Matarese I got problems and
they need fixing
all right all right you're gonna have to
go through hell worse than any nightmare
you have a dream if I can change and you
can change
you're listening to fixing Joe every
week I'm gonna bring my real life
problems with this podcast my friends my
listeners my guests my family they're
all gonna help me and trust me i need it
i got tons of problems I'm anxious I OCD
I have a DD I'm narcissistic I'm
insecure I got anger out the ass and all
these things come together to ruin my
life all the time I'm hoping this show
can help you're listening to fixing Joe
hey how are you everybody thanks for
tuning in to another fixing Joe would
you say tuning in if it's just the
podcast I guess you would say tuning in
listening in downloading I appreciate
you thanks so much hi mom here a little
late night little Wednesday late night
just doing the beginning of the podcast
I already recorded my guest i actually
had a guest for today's podcast you
probably saw his name in the title the
great Jake Johansen one of my F favorite
comedians he's a little older than me so
I do remember watching him many times
growing up um I guess tonight show
Letterman's geez he's been on Letterman
like 40 to 50 times I know it's
somewhere in that range I've had him on
the podcast maybe a couple of years ago
I remember recording it in at levity
live in the green room there he was kind
enough to do my podcast then and he's
kind enough to do it today I appreciate
you Jake Johansen what plugs do we have
before we get to my guest I want to plug
this date I have at the great club of
the Laughing Skull in Atlanta Georgia
I'll be there this week the 22nd through
the 25th in Atlanta Georgia the Laughing
Skull I think it's laughing skull lounge
com if you want to come out and get
tickets to that
that's where you go okay and of course I
will be opening for Bill Baer at the
wells fargo center on November 6th in
Philadelphia where I started comedy
pretty cool full circle hopefully uh
they like me scary when you're opening
for somebody and it's it's that many
people you know because I've had I've
had some tough shows in the past he's
usually when I was opening for Artie
Artie Lange when the Howard Stern Show
was something he was doing daily and
sometimes you would get the fans it just
didn't want any openers they just want
Artie and I know bill burr's fans will
be a little bit different than that and
hopefully they're fine with an opening
act so buy tickets to that the wells
fargo center november six something new
that i'm offering you fixing Joe fans is
more than just the two cds that i've
offered for donations now if you make a
twenty dollar donation on joe Matarese
com is where you make the donations you
make a twenty dollar donation in my
podcast you get two of my CDs for free
you get disconnected my last stand up
album and you also get when a comedian
attacks which is all hecklers before I
was on celexa the anti-anxiety
medication amount you get those two
albums and a pair of tweaked audio
earbuds as you know they're a sponsor
for the podcast if you want to get a
thirty percent discount to anything
tweaked audio cells go to tweaked audio
com twee ke D tweaked audio dot-com you
you put fixing Joe in the promo code
window and you get a thirty percent
discount off of all their merchandise
okay so you make a twenty dollar
donation get those two CDs and the
earbuds if you make a thirty dollar
donation you also get my fixing Joe
album which was the CD album that i did
before disconnected if you donate forty
dollars you get every
d I've ever done you get the four CDs
you get quiet please which is the first
CD I ever did recorded it at Stan of New
York fixing Joe is recorded at go
bananas in Cincinnati Ohio and
disconnected is I think it's also
recorded at go bananas in Cincinnati
Ohio it is and when convenient acts of
course is all different clubs all over
the place so make those donations of
course you get the earbuds but also with
all those CD orders okay do it help me
out get all four of my CDs I will send
you all the downloads for those okay
cool um other than that I I want to get
right to the interview with Jake
Johansen let me look at my list to see
if there's anything that I didn't get to
really talk about with Jake that was on
my list
I didn't I didn't get to talk about this
because I knew he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but one of the fans who listens to the
podcast and follows me on Twitter oh
that's what I need to plug also we need
to get that Twitter up to 10,000 for me
to be able to sell my special right
think I met 9700 right now follow me on
twitter at the joe Matarese we have a
few weeks try to get me over the ten
thousand mark looks good let's get there
at the joe Matarese okay so i didn't get
to talk to a jake about this but someone
tweeted saying they were you know just
slamming me saying they were sick of the
driveway pictures does that mean he's
sick of me talking about my house
projects I guess he got him on Twitter I
don't know if we watched a periscope I
definitely periscope mean doing that
hole widening job do you guys feel the
same way listeners are you annoyed when
I talk about my house project or I tweet
about them and I send you a picture
because you you ask so then I send a
picture and then a bunch of people come
out slamming me for these pictures let
me know Matarese 67 @ gmail.com is my
email let me know if you if you feel the
same way okay that was all I really
wanted to get out I talked about
everything else on my list with Jake
Johansen I didn't really get out a lot
about the Eagles be in first place and
me thinking they suck because Jake
wasn't really a football fan but I I'll
say this real quick let's be honest I'm
not excited they're in first place
they're not very good sam bradford threw
three interceptions come on I just don't
think through that great they're you
know they're not good that they played
good green bay packers or they plate
Cincinnati or they played the the New
England Patriots they would get
destroyed especially if it was an
important game like a playoff game they
would get killed okay that's just what I
wanted to say in a quick summary I did a
long periscope a few days ago
going on it was the morning after monday
night football talking all about the
Eagles I don't know if you saw that
follow me on periscope too because you
can you can watch all those things so
let's get to the interview Jake Johansen
skyped in from from santa monica
california i know he lives a few blocks
from the beach and let's get to that
interview everybody all right we'll be
right back ah well thanks for taking the
time out to do the podcast again this is
the second time you've been on trying to
think how long ago we did what up cuz
that was at levity we were both it
working at levity live remember up in
West Nyack yeah I remember we did it in
the green room there I haven't been back
have you been back to West Nyack I don't
know no I've been there I'm he I'm there
here and there cuz that clubs like it's
right by its 30 minutes away I moved
since that you probably did it I live a
little closer to New York City but uh
yeah yeah that was uh maybe it was two
years ago does that sound about right I
think that sounds right and you have it
back there and you don't know why have
you done well Gotham and then have you
done yeah well it's the same owner yeah
it is but they get their mathematics of
who they have in and you know maybe I
these young kids that work for peanuts
yeah i know i'm at um I'm the same as
you well i'm old and i'll work for
peanuts you'll just not take the date I
think well I feel like for peanuts I'd
rather do I'd rather do a gig where
there's 150 people who all paid for a
ticket than a weekend where there's
2,000 people that you know they gave
away free tickets who don't know you
know first I got to teach him who I am
then I got to teach him what a comedy
show is and then we're kind of done
right so um so I you know we'll talk
we'll talk some subjects on on my I
stopped having a lot of guests on my
podcast but I have hard to get Cass yeah
I just stopped even trying to get guess
I was like I'm doing him by myself but I
have this guy who's helping me produce
my podcast now and he's doing a really
good job and I guess he texted me he's
not a techie reached out to me to do
your podcast but then you know there was
a lot of back and forth and I wasn't
sure whether we booked it he was like
hey just FYI it's on for tomorrow and
I'm like okay well how do we do it and
then he sends me your skype handle and
then he goes Oh on second thought Joe's
doing Artie Lange stinks so he can't do
it it's like look I kind of I like Joe
and I cleared the decks because I
thought you knew what Joe was doing but
you don't know
oh I don't know about this guy I can't
tell I can't tell if I'm is communicated
with him or not I do remember there was
the way we're no don't yet we are here
now but there was a moment where I went
what one o'clock i'm gonna be at artie's
like I remember thinking I needed to I
needed it to be later and which didn't
work for you so it would have had to be
four to work for you and have probably
been eleven thirty at night and then i'm
flying to atlanta tomorrow morning i
really wouldn't wanted to do a podcast
it'll let me learn it do that were you
going to atlanta what are you doing I'm
doing the Laughing Skull yeah I like
that place I like it makes war that's an
example of a place where I feel like
they paid fairly it's small so you don't
make a bunch of money but the people who
are there want to see the show and you
want to do the show yeah and you get a
delicious burger after every show the
food is 0 when you're in Atlanta
listeners please stop by the Laughing
Skull to see Joe or I or any of the
other last time I was there I got to be
in this movie that they did I was about
to say I saw the trailer today on your
litter and I watched it I was like what
because I knew that what was cool about
the Laughing Skull is that they have
that group of guys they have the down
stay of the people listening this comedy
club owner Marshalls a comedian he's
really cool he hired a lot of guys that
are also comedians and her film makers
and editors and some animators I saw a
guy who animated something for me once
who was in the trailer so I have a
feeling he might have had something to
do with writing them this movie that
you're in what's a cold uh-uh that's
good that you don't know it's a way I
don't know I can't remember everything i
do not have paid that well it paid zero
general like the only people in it are
the comedians who were doing the gig but
it's super fun because you get to they
would make up it was improvised and it
was really fun but yet Marshalls running
an artist call it's like he's doing like
an Andy Warhol thing except there's not
drugs and they're not all having sex
with each other as far as I could tell
maybe they all had sex after I left the
one of the got the guy I'm talking about
his in the trailer as his head shaved I
don't know if what his name is I'm
forgetting I probably see him this week
and I'm getting there he was in the
trailer when I worked at the Laughing
Skull
last time he was on a couple of the
shows he was passing a kidney stone
backstage is going I mean this guy I
thought he was gonna die I'm like you
need to go to the emergency room heat it
took like like a hair he took heroin or
something it was like a pill I swear to
god he took heroin and then did a set on
it I was like how are you able to even
go on stage and then like an hour later
he comes with this little black dot on
his hand and he goes this is the kidney
stone that I just passed I mean I
couldn't believe how small it was and
how much pain he was in no smaller than
BB yeah it was it was like a speck have
you ever passed a kidney stone known
that I guess they really hurt and
they're not that big and you got to do
heroin cuz they're not smooth like a
baby either they got edges on him yes it
had edges he showed me I was like oh god
damn well you can get it just imagine
what it feels like to have some little
tiny thing like that in your shoe I know
like it hurts when that's in your shoe
now imagine p and i'll leave that thing
out well good well yeah so these guys
are like now that they made an official
movie i mean it looks like a real movie
it's like you Chris franjola is in it it
is a real look Jim Florentines in it
yeah it looks it looks good I mean it
looked interesting so good for Marshall
trials yeah well good for all of us for
all of us do it for all of our earrings
that's the way to do it yeah don't you
hate when you're it's funny when you get
these gigs now we're um you have to do
something and if you say no you're
afraid they might never book you again
like that comes into my head like there
was I'm not gonna say the name of that a
lot of these clubs have they have
cameras in the back this happens a lot
they go oh we videotaped your whole set
can we chop it up and we're gonna put it
on this site and I'm like why would I
let you know I always say no so do i
yeah you got to say no to that you're a
rooftop that's rooftop yeah they're
terrible I was afraid of them they're
terrible no you shouldn't be afraid of
them they should be afraid of you yeah
but then they my ibook i wouldn't win
rooftop comedies in charge and whether
or not i get booked
that's I'll find a place where they're
not there's a lot of places where they
aren't like I can go this is where my
new thing is I'm doing a tour of just
you know American Legion halls and Elks
clubs I'm gonna to neighborhood part i'm
gonna go i'm going back to the
neighborhood bar they got it set up with
you I'll tell you what the thing the
half the time that they want you to do
for free is five of the shows they pay
you for one of the shows and then you do
the other five shows for free that's how
it seems to me at some of these clubs
well here in the east in the Northeast
that's what most of my gigs are nowadays
are what you just said the Elks clubs
the fundraisers and you probably feel
the same the bat though the best shows I
do they're better than the comedy holes
I did a show in this town called sequim
on the Olympic Peninsula swim that's the
name of the town right it's and it was
it was in the country club like the golf
course they sold 100 I was the second
time I've done it they sold out in two
days there's a hundred and fifty hundred
eighty people there they have the
greatest time and then and then we all
have a drink after the show it was
terrific yeah I liked it yeah I've done
a lot what I want to do now I'm just I I
don't need a ton of money but I I need 0
headache I just don't need any more
headache and I don't need so here's what
happened to me today Joe I knew I was on
your show i thought i'm gonna i'm not
i'm not just gonna have the whole day
just be devoted to this podcast because
i feel like i need to get some other
things done so i went to costco i'm
getting in the car in costco the NPR is
on a pledge drive so i need a CD I reach
in the little you know that net bag
thing that's on the side of the console
guess what cds in there my when
audiences attack my comedians day when
comedians attack it's like you dealing
with these chips in the crowd so I just
I don't know I was just listening to you
on that cuz n PR was on pledge break so
I just listened to that today and it
made me feel like yet this is the
terrible side of what we do for a living
I don't need some drunk lady who doesn't
understand that she's at a show like I'm
I'm the entertainment at the thing that
you
bought a ticket to or got a free ticket
to I don't care if you have the ticket
or not it's a ticket you got a ticket
and you came to this thing that's me we
have to be quiet I'm doing the show
you're watching the show how hard is
that to understand its i was listening
to Marc Maron interview Mike Epps on his
podcast Justin just now just got out of
the car was listening to it and it I
don't have any of the anger left I take
antidepressants like that whole album
you heard is probably five years and
further back before I took yeah I it's
weird though because I don't have that
anger anymore that I really don't have
someone heckle me like that anymore it's
I don't I don't experience that very
often either they did the worst that it
is is late at night when just people
just don't they won't be quiet it was
like just too excited but when I was
angrier I swear to god it happened
probably every tenth show like you're
you feel like you were attracting it I'm
not yeah you must when you're like when
angers on the surface for you it the you
know it goes there you get those people
I don't know what it is it sets them off
I i believe that i believe that well
yeah if you're an angry person then
you're gonna you may be delivering some
subtle angry cues that other people are
picking up on and then they react in
anger you know well Marc Maron was
explaining to my gaps on the on the
podcast at his that this just got me a
little angry and I don't have a lot of
the anger left he was taping a special
and a lady in the middle of it said
could I get my picture with you like a
drunk lady like tried to come up on
stage to take a picture and I was like
with marc maron with marc maron in the
middle of him with a fight you know a
taping a special there's cameras and
guys with cameras everywhere filming to
do that is just that's just insane it
like got me angry I was like yep that
those are the people that suck can you
believe that but they just don't
understand it's like they're so out of
control I mean you can't even say that
they're selfish the thing is that
they're just out of their own minds they
don't even know what they're doing
they're just
wrong so let's get to the list of topics
for the podcast today I know I know k
which is that this is the thing your
podcast is about me helping you right
well it's evolved it's not okay it's not
a lot about those situations and in
stuff that's kind of what it probably
was when i did it with you now it's more
just like you know I talk about what
happened in my life that week okay and
some of it is a problem that could have
advice from you and other of it of other
stuff isn't and you know talk I'm sure
what happens in your life will come up I
don't know if your are you a football
fan you know Joe I'm a heterosexual and
I can watch sports and enjoy them not
that that's purely a heterosexual thing
but I'm not driven by sports and I can't
my wife is not and so we don't really
i'll watch sports if i'm on the road and
you say hey we're gonna spend the
afternoon watching this game i'll watch
it with you don't have a great time but
otherwise I don't know what's going tell
you what I do want to see is the Rugby
World Cup because the All Blacks that's
the New Zealand team is playing me
they're called the All Blacks yeah
that's the name of the team yet they
were all black then we're all black what
country All Blacks New Zealand it's New
Zealand team oh yeah so they're playing
on saturday Saturday morning yeah the
All Blacks when you wear the shirt
around and it's got an adidas logo so
it'll say all blacks and then right
above that it'll say adidas so it's like
a real sports shirt but sometimes when
you're going through airport security
with that on people are like a what you
know but it's and that's their team do
you have the shirt like you want sears
hello you have an aunt like shirt and I
have an All Blacks hat I don't I wish I
had it I didn't think to have it handy
right now oh here you can see the guys
that there's the poster of there can you
see that on my cydia All Blacks yeah
that's the that's their haka that's
their Maori war dance that they do it's
fun in a game because there's probably
not a lot of black people in New Zealand
that's kind of
like a I'm just so I mean what are you
complaining about they're all black you
know I mean you can't really get mad
about back linea so so so rugby is the
sport you would pick of you if I said
Jake what's the sport that you like to
sit down and watch and follow you would
say right I don't think I could watch
this any rugby but I do like to watch
the all blacks because I root for them
and it's to me it's a fun sport because
it's almost slapstick the physicality
it's like football they go running I
know what it is I sort of like they're
playing one second you think they're
playing soccer and then they run and
crash into each other and then fight
wrestle for the ball and then it comes
shooting out and then one of them kicks
it to someone else and then they fight
wrestle him and they don't have any pads
and they just slam into each other so
hard and their giant muscular dudes yeah
this guy from Ireland are used to be my
plumber when I lived in my old house he
played rugby and all his key at five
four boys they all played rugby and it's
just it's one of those sports that you
know you don't want to [ __ ] with that
guy if he plays rugby that's just a
sport he doesn't care if you punch him
in the mouth really hard he'll probably
just smile and then yeah I did idea
they're working out stuff you know those
guys well I was gonna I was gonna bring
up the Philadelphia Eagles but you uh
have a friend who's an Eagles plan and I
like filler to Philadelphia is a tough
town they had kidding around in
Philadelphia no that's where that's I'm
from right outside of Philly so I I
follow them but they've been so bad this
year and it's like depressing like
they're literally in first place and
they suck that's how bad wait how can
you be in first place and suck because
they're in the I have to I'll explain it
to you as a nonce football guy the rest
of the division is even more sucky yeah
well they're tied for first there three
and three they ever yet everyone and
then the NFC East is what they're in
sucks mm-hm and then you see these other
teams like the Patriots in the green bay
packers I mean they're insanely good so
like it makes me not even want to watch
because I'm like what's the point I know
if they get anywhere they're eventually
going to have the
one of these actually good first-place
teams and get destroyed so I'm just not
really not really into it but they just
they just beat the cowboys and or not
the Cowboys the Giants on Monday Night
Football and you know oh I'm maybe we
can use this as I don't know if you go
you have a daughter yes dish nah I i
have this thing my son's funny like he
won't root for the team that I like and
he'll say to me why should I like the
Eagles dad I live in New York and like I
don't i'm not one of those dads that cuz
now you like with dad like you're an
eagles fan like I'm not that guy I'm my
car I like the giants like okay I get it
you live in New York you're probably
right I almost think I shouldn't like
the the Philadelphia team anymore
because I've been living in New York for
more than I lived in Philadelphia been
here 25 years well I've heard a lot
about your son but I don't know him
you're my friend i want to be clear
about that but he's talking a lot of
sense yeah he makes a sudden yeah i feel
like i've got a friend who got me into
baseball when I was you know in my 20s I
wasn't a fan of baseball when I was a
kid and then I I got into it when I was
in my 20s when I lived in San Francisco
and then I came down here and I was a
giants fan until I kind of went off
baseball a little bit but he kind of he
came to LA he became an angels fan and
then like they were all about the Angels
he and his daughter but then they moved
to Massachusetts another red sox fans
you know so yeah yeah yeah I don't
realize that that that happens I guess
cuz Philly so dominant that youth like
my brother told me that he's right he's
taking me out of the will that was the
text I got cuz I was rooting for the
Mets because they're in the playoffs
uh-huh I live in New York and he goes
there in our division I'm like the
Phillies are out of it they're out of it
so what is the problem I don't
understand if my team's out of it and I
root for someone in our division I think
that's fine it's a character mentality
these people are trying to put on your
show you've got two separate yourselves
from them it's not healthy I mean come
on he's gonna write you out of the will
cuz you're rooting for a different team
how much do you need the money do you
need the money I would go
I don't think you're gonna write me out
of the will for that yeah I'm a person
I'm rooting for the team that's by my
house I got a child I can't afford to
fly to philly with my kid to go see a
game in a stadium where they probably my
child's gonna witness a crime while
we're going to buy a hot dog that's true
well if you tried even if my son which
where's giants shirt or hat or whatever
to an english giants game in philly my
eight-year-old son would might get close
to getting his ass kicked like that's
how crazy it is yes gonna get a free
battery that's for sure they're gonna
throw a battery at I could they still do
that Joe throw batteries they probably
do i remove all they're famous for
throwing snowballs at UM santa claus
that's what they're famous for these
fans they just pelted the [ __ ] out of
sand yeah that's not the real sand i
just want to point out Santa that's at
the football game that's not a real
Santa that's it person that they hire so
I mean I'm not coming to the aid of the
fans I think it's a shitty thing to do
to even throw a snowball at the guy is
just trying to make a living pretending
to be Santa but it would be a whole
nother thing if you were throwing a
snowball at the real Santa yeah you just
exude what like of California I just
feel it like you can just feel it so I
as I'm talking to you I can tell cuz
I've been to your house so that might
give it away I know you're near the
beach you can just see the like hey
whatever I don't there's a game i'm
gonna i'm not i don't really wanna what
it's weird how that mentality in New
York it is it is different I was going
to go to this bar there's a British bar
here to watch the rugby world cup
windows England's plan on saturday
morning at eight in the morning here in
California that's why have to go to the
bar at eight in the morning to watch it
but I read online that it's gonna be
there charging a twenty dollar cover to
watch I'm not going to go to a bar to
watch rug pay twenty dollar cover for 17
more dollars I can't just buy the
pay-per-view in my house was about to
say the only way it should cost twenty
dollars if it's a pay-per-view but that
sounds like it's rude but I mean it's
come on really you can't just pony up
for the bar who else is gonna be in
there drinking at eight in the morning
it's all gravy plus you got to make
twenty dollars i bet those rugby fans or
not
sigh bet like a bacon burger they have
like a line at eight in the morning I
bet especially if it's hard to get on TV
where I don't you where do you pay per
view that just normal pay per view like
at an email to click I think that that
game is actually on NBC really that game
by ID but because it's a semifinal and I
think it's on NBC so there may not be a
cover I wouldn't even know what the
hell's happening if I was watching I
know there's like there's kind of like a
weird goalpost that's narrow and there's
just guys with shorts and long sleeve
shirts right yeah it's sort of CLE you
gotta break the plane with the ball to
score but they don't call it a touchdown
the call it a try so like I scored a try
yeah they're like nice try and I gotta
try nice try and that's a high scoring
game right no no it's pretty low scoring
and then so it's 66 for a try and then
you get to kick an extra point which is
one or if you run it across its too so
that's similar to football but then the
rest is is different because it's you
know there's no breaks it just kind of
keeps going that Harley's stop the clock
and if you come out you're out you know
so guys are just running around bashing
into each other bleeding like their
noses will start bleeding they'll just
stuff some rag in there because if once
you come out you don't get sub back in
you're out it's like baseball you play
until you're out then you're at home and
you get some small little injury you
can't go fix it and come back you're
done yeah always open the claret you
know Clarence red wine and that's with
some guy get hit in the nose and he'll
start just gushing blood together always
tap the claret oh that's what they say
and then you have yeah so these guys
stay in all banged up if they can stop
the blood from going yeah yeah they stay
in how do they stop the board of someone
run out and can they someone throw them
a rag I mean what happened I think yeah
they can get thrown a rag or I think if
you start bleeding they'll let you take
a little time you know time out to sea
hey see if you can get that stopped we
don't need to bleed not everybody else
and is there half timers just play
straight through there is half time the
other is half time they do stop the
clock for a couple of things it's not
like soccer where it keeps rolling and
then they have that mystery overtime at
the end yeah nice tan yeah so the here's
the second subject
my list this just happened this happened
I know it didn't have a last night it
happened Monday night I do i do like I
call them city spots I live in the burbs
but I it's you know 25 minute drive i do
spots I'm sure you do the same you drive
in ever to the improv and do like a set
sometimes i'm on the road enough i've
been trying to do more of those because
i feel like they're good for me both
comedy-wise because you're performing
for some kind of different types of
crowds and mental health wise because
you're hanging out with more of your
peers on your on your level you know
when you're on the road you meet a lot
of great guys and i have met a lot of
great guys who have gone on to then be
big national names on a road but that
hanging out the city spots are fun fun
hangout time so you're doing a city spot
it's but you just made me think of this
as a side note my wife gets mad when
there's those guys that like open for
you years ago and then all of a sudden
they become a household name she gets
upset yeah like we know what she needs
to check her diploma she's a therapist
Joe I know my wife doesn't do therapy
but she is a psychologist like I said
she'd know that we're all gonna get old
and die and that some people are at a
point in their career where they're
taking off and other people are at a
point where they've kind of reached
their altitude and they're cruising and
then there's wine down later on in your
life and you can't always tell where you
are in your cycle but other people are
being successful and you're their friend
there's nothing wrong that's that's not
bad what's good she gets upset when it's
someone that we both thought was like
terrible like it's someone that we go
ahead guys this person sucks and then
somehow they get famous she actually
said this recently I said something like
this girl comic we know just got this
writing job for some new show on HBO and
my wife literally goes up she goes
happens all the time I got the same
ringer yeah she goes the best ringer my
wife goes of course she got a writing
job she knows you like everyone I know
gets better things than me think ah I
got that that hurt a little bit
ok so this happens at this comedy club
Monday night so there's this club in the
city we get a lot of certain clubs here
in New York City it will be hundred
percent tourists and when I say hundred
percent tourists most of them are from
not in the United States and a lot of
them English is their second or third
language and you get a lot of these like
a silly place to do comedy show but okay
yeah but something are those people are
never going to become established
Americans and then buy a ticket to your
show later or are you planning a trip to
ya be dhabi or wherever they're from
well no I mean that's not racist because
I don't know where they are from so I'm
allowed to make up a silly country name
like that but by the way but as a
comedian do you ever get like I should
be able to make all people laugh even
like okay they speak English they're
following me but you know you'll hit
those moments and you don't realize it
to your already added in the joke they
don't know what I'm talking yeah they
don't know who Ray Rice's they don't
know there was an incident yeah I'm
gonna need to get brought up to speed on
ray rice a little bit but okay he's a
football he's if I knew he was a
football player is the one who punched
out his wife yeah and drug her out of
the elevator yeah I like to be given a
chance to guess before you tell me just
refutes in the rest of this conversation
well this is what happened has nothing
to do with them not getting me or
anything this was more just my risky
mistake and made me maybe being in a bad
zone every once in a while I go in and
do these City spots and I don't know if
I don't have new material to try and I'm
doing my old material I'll feel like a
piece of [ __ ] where am I don't enjoy
doing the material I've already crafted
I it's like I'd rather do stuff that I
don't know where it goes but then you
have a bad set most of the time that's
what happened if I do feel like you
start off doing the the stuff that
you're working on and then use it then
you go to the things that work so that
in in the hole by the end you've
entertained them yeah I got the stupid
Louis CK in my head that we throw away
all the old material and we start fresh
because I just taped the special but I
not at the place where I have a whole
new out like tomorrow flying into
atlanta um i was there a year ago and i
hate when i get somewhere and I'm like I
don't have a whole new I don't have a
whole new our one of the reasons is
that's it huh these are man I must have
a TD today because it but one of the
reasons why is I actually taped an album
there a year ago but we ended up not
releasing it so I had to save all the
material and then when I taped a special
I did it and it's that was about seven
months ago so really I've only been
working on new material for seven months
I don't have an hour i have about 25 25
minutes maybe which is present but uh
yeah i'll be a little in my head at the
Laughing Skull doing some of the older
stuff that they're gonna be like he said
he doesn't have all new you shouldn't do
you have all new in a year later when
you go to a club that's not how that's
not how normal people turn their acts
over a whole new hour every year louis
ck has to do that Pilbara ass to do that
but that's not a real world thing these
the people at the Laughing Skull you
want to do a good show for them not not
all hey here's some things you haven't
heard that aren't so good you want
they're not all gonna have seen you
before either that's true you know that
would be amazing if it was all the same
exactly you baby huge draw if that
happened recently is sold out Madison
Square Garden I think for shows uh-huh
and the Laughing Skull seats 95 people
well you know what's funny and that you
said bill burr is I'm doing the Laughing
Skull whatsit seat 80 I think it's 95
but I could be wrong the following week
I'm opening for Bill bar in Philadelphia
in my hometown I asked him if I could be
on that show that he's doing at the
wells fargo center where the Sixers and
the Flyers play they'll be between 12
and 15 thousand people I've never done
that that big so I'll have from 80 to
15,000 it's pretty funny already thought
that was like hilarious i'm doing I
think it's sunny well that's comedy that
stand-up comedy and that's we're always
two going from one weird extreme to
another weird extreme I'll tell you
something if I was
siding which show I wanted to see I'd
rather go see a show in a 95 a good show
in a 95 seat room than a good show in a
10,000 seat room oh sure it's gonna be a
no-brainer my parents got they had
though I had to let them buy tickets I
didn't even want to ask bill to comp my
family my mom my dad and my brother and
sister are coming and they're gonna
they're sitting in the last row of the
place because I was yeah by the time you
pay the popcorn vendors in the parking
lot attendants he probably is makin just
write about the same as what you're
making for the laughing stock you know
you can't you try to not think about it
in your head but I'm like he might make
a million dollars that not well maybe
not that night unless they had a second
show on you might not gonna have a
million hmm he might be making a half a
million doing that math I mean I don't
like howling seats whatever so this is
get back to your sister this is this is
what happens at the Broadway comedy club
this uh-huh this was that's the one
where you're in Times Square and there's
guys trying to give you free tickets oh
yeah definitely yeah so this girl goes
on before me who's like I am not sure if
you've experienced this yet but it seems
like in the last year year and a half
I've experienced it a couple times where
there's like a transgender type comedian
where you can't tell is this a guy
turning into a girls this is a girl
turning into a guy is this just the
lesbian like it you don't know now that
who this girl went on stage and I had
never witnessed this where I can't tell
if she's a girl or a guy and I can't
tell by listening to her she's a girl or
a guy she sounds like a girl and a guy
at the same time and looks like a girl
and a guy and she's an african-american
girl right and then she she was funny or
guy and we're guy and she was funny and
she went up there in her first joke with
something like I know what you're
thinking and she just kind of paused and
I think maybe the punch line was I'm
black something like that and and so I
go on after her and I don't know if this
is the world we're in now or people just
they get so easily like huh but I went
on after and I just said I know am I
opened with I know what you're thinking
I'm a guy and I said something like I
like vagina or something like that like
just like what this young guy and I like
women I'm married like I can I try to
keep it going and I just they got so
uncomfortable that I had a bat I had a
bad set do you think it was that you
just got on the wrong side of their
politically incorrect incorrect sort of
filter thing it was one oolitic ille I
don't know if you have this happen my
wife will say it too cuz my wife was at
my special and she said I wasn't
completely off of it but my likability
my nice guy sometimes comes out as
[ __ ] like I don't even know why like
I'll be a likable guy she's like you're
so funny when you're just in a good mood
and being likable and then there's this
occasional set and like I said before
the meds it was every tenth set that's
probably when I would get the heckler
but I like in my head I kind of knew as
I was saying this about the person who
went on before me like I would tell any
comedian don't address the comedian
before you like unless you got something
nice and funny if you're saying
something like about a transgender
person like it kind of sounds like
you're an ass like well you're an
[ __ ] like you're not accepting of her
like what is your problem like yeah I
was almost you only want to talk the
only time I ever want to refer to
somebody before me is if I have
something clever to add that then is
like hey you can have that joke next
time if you want it or or or it's some
like I it turns out on the butt of the
joke that they just told you know they
tell some story about somebody who does
some terrible thing and then I go up and
do some reveal that I'm that guy I'm
that jerk you know but you want to be
self-deprecating you don't want to be
and you definitely don't want to be
criticizing then we're all in the same
fraternity but it seems like from what
you said you accidentally got
interpreted as though you criticize this
person but you didn't really do it that
is that was not your intention it wasn't
my intention but I think I did do it
like almost as I was saying it there was
a little voice in the back of my head
going don't say this your this that's
this is not this isn't nice do you think
this is that turn
this is like you're just turning old
this is like this is the version of my
dad going leg there's a lot of black
people in here like dad it could be yeah
that's funny that my dad doesn't my mom
oh my god she would hit she listen to my
podcast sometimes but she'll say we took
her to see fireworks yeah where we live
you know where we live borders up
against the Bronx and you know
Westchester just below Westchester is
the Bronx there are a lot of
spanish-speaking people to live there's
a lot of spanish-speaking people that
live in Westchester also and my mom
can't not say it when we go to see
fireworks she's like are we in America
that's what she said like yeah we go we
are America is a melting pot show and
then we are just the white meat and in
the melting pot there's a lot of other
meat in the melting pot is she can't not
say it I definitely have that treat
where it's like I try to not say it but
I can't I'm told that's an a.d.d tray by
the way saying things that are a little
inappropriate out of line maybe that's
why it came out of my mouth at my set
yeah could be are you recovered from it
do you feel better now I feel like I I'm
done a couple of shows since so it's
kind of out of me but I'm wondering cuz
you and I are pretty like nice guys when
we're on stage we're not it we're not
edgy and mean like a like a bill burr
might be a little tougher in a little he
says some aggressive things and that's
what's funny about him cuz that's true
to how he is every once in a while I'll
get into it I'll get into trouble for
doing something that was completely
unintentional but I think most of the
time I can get out of it because the
audience is like he did you know I'll be
able to say look that wasn't my
intention right well it's like it's
funny cuz you asked who Ray Rice was and
I did know who he was I just couldn't I
didn't have it in my mind but I once
used one sweet i was getting it right
before you said it it's it's it's also
interesting because i remember that
night when i made the comment about that
girl then I went into a joke that's edgy
that if I'm not likable if I'm not being
likable me this jokes not going to work
right a nice and I just want I shouldn't
have done that joke either and I did
that next second which is about the Ray
Rice and domestic violence and I have a
joke about him there was a viral video I
don't know if you saw it and I left it
in my special and not this was a bit I
wasn't sure if I should leave am i
special because it's about hitting women
my wife wants thought I should take it
out but I'm like I I like it I don't
know why I like you're gonna be on TV or
is it a five dollar download or is it my
last special was five Bella download I
don't know what those pictures of my
dinner everybody and you can get it at
my website check this calm okay now back
to you Joe it depends if it sells or not
I had investors and now we're gonna try
to my management will take it around see
if they can sell it hopefully it's not a
download hopefully can sell it because i
went to i'm gonna say and hopefully what
happened to me doesn't happen to you
well did you have investors that you
have to pay back or do you pay for it
yourself yeah my wife my wife was mine
it's me and my wife we spent our money
invested in ourselves okay yeah so I'm
on the hook I'm mad at myself that's how
at least you have other people who are
mad at you that's a good feeling cuz you
don't have to be both people like I'm
pissed that I sprinted away my money but
then also hahaha i frittered away
somebody else's money did you try to
sell its own network i did and i don't
know what happened well i know that show
time has changed how many specials they
bought her had changed this was last
year or the beginning of this you know
whatever i'm probably in for a big
uphill battle to sell a specials pretty
hard i know a few guys that are big
comedians like you that are sold it salt
sell it outright and you know it seems
like they do all right if you have a big
enough fan base selling it yourself you
know yeah yeah well it could be that i
didn't have those 10,000 twitter
followers that you need you gotta I
gotta get him I'm gonna but two so they
like the autumn I'll tell you the joke
though so yes this is it this isn't
didn't guess what I was going to say so
what is the joke that you followed up
with so I follow up with this joke about
this viral video um and it [ __ ] I
can't I don't to explain the joke that's
before it but the joke is a lot about
just a video game system that was used
that we gave my kid as a birthday
present our friends of ours gave us this
old system
and I wrapped it up and gave it to him
like the joke is how I rewrapped it and
gave it to him and I go was obviously
old it came with madden 09 there were I
go now you have to know football to get
the joke which is you know probably not
a good Broadway comedy clubs not the
place to do it they're all foreign and
i'm doing a joke about how it had Ray
Rice when he you know Ray Rice when he
was a good boyfriend and the Adrian
Peterson when he was a really great debt
Adrian Peterson was in the news last
year for hidden his kid very excessively
and they I think they sis they suspended
him for a while and same way ray rice
both of them were are eligible to play
again but Adrian Peterson is playing
again but no one picked up Ray Rice he's
still out um so then the second part of
the joke is about this viral video where
this kid this he's like an 18 year old
boy he's on the subway and this girl is
literally swinging at him like almost
hitting them and just verbally abusing
him and he's taking it in the video he's
just kind of almost getting hit and
she's just kind of yelling in his face
and then you see her swing a little
harder and hit his phone and it flies
out of his hand and goes shooting across
the subway floor and he just looks at
her and you literally in the video see a
switch click and he just swings out her
full full boat like hard open hand but
full swing and then all these guys tried
to stand up and like fight this guy you
know because they think it's out of line
that he's hitting a woman and basically
on stage you know the joke is I don't
think men should be able to hit women
but we should be able to hit one total
[ __ ] a year and I and I then I tell
them this [ __ ] story about this woman
who waited for me after a show once with
these really long fingernails just
yelling at me and she flicks cigarette
ashes in my eyes mm-hmm and then I go I
should be able to hit her and then say
uh-oh what's the punchline of the joke
uh I go you have a jiffy lube sticker in
your wallet it shows you know keeps
track of your [ __ ] hits and you just go
hey easy guys easy it's okay it's been
13 months I was
do you know so some it's weird when I'm
being likable as mean as that joke
sounds I can get it to kill all the way
through and when I say I want to hit one
bit you should be able to hit one [ __ ]
a year they'll actually in my special it
gets in a full applause break because
it's like I described it in the way like
these guys getting punched in the face
by a girl and he can hit her back and
she's a girl I disagree like maybe
that's just how I say it should say the
joke and I cannot sure I can fix this
one Joe because it seems a little trick
this area difficulty this joke right you
gotta get it you got to get it right
like you said they have to be on board
with you and your point of view funny I
imagine that you told about the kid on
the subway i definitely feel like look
you can screw the guy to a certain point
and then once you cross the line it's
like look this is the this is the reason
it's not okay to hit people right as
they might hit you back right you you
know you want to do unto others how you
want them to do unto you but you can't
kind of punch somebody and then get mad
because they hit you right exact right
now have you ever been punched by a
woman in your lifetime I can't think of
it but I'm not a punchy guy don't get in
fights when you were young never you
never did right that I might have got in
a fight but I don't think I mean you
know maybe I was also sort of a [ __ ]
but I wasn't too you know I never felt
like I was gonna win so if you don't
think you're gonna win a fight you try
not to get into a fight you try not to
even be the guy who you know and usually
it's that other guys who want to fight
they want you to hit them first so that
they feel like they got the green light
to do whatever they want that's right
well I'm gonna just keep walking away
right situation let's once again it's
before the medication there were there
were instances a lot of my hecklers back
when I was angry were women well a lot
of that listening to that CD you'd
threaten physical violence a lot well
yeah I was her head off or I wanna punch
you or all this other that's like the
reality is you don't really want to do
those things because if you do those
things you can there's gonna be legal
awe as soon as you punch someone and
hurt them
they're gonna go lawyer up and sue you
sue your ass even if they hit you first
well it's amazing as bad as that my
anger was back then and all that stuff
that I would say that was so aggressive
never got in a fight like I was never a
fighting guy it's weird it would just on
stage happen I walk off stage and then
feel horrible like I wouldn't be I
wouldn't continue where I'm like where
is he I'm gonna punch him in the fit
like that never happened it was weird
how it all dropped out as soon as I say
good night like I just felt like
crawling in a hole and I was embarrassed
I was embarrassed of myself thank god
cuz I'm really thank God we got that
pill maybe I should get rid of rid of
this see it rid of that album it sells
bigger than anything I have that CD if I
sell it after shows they want it but you
taught you start off talking about
everybody at everybody that's
everybody's favorite question is what do
you do about hecklers like I've got a CD
called the CD that's called my website
to Jake this calm CD and that's got some
alternative tracks which are the same
tracks that are earlier on the CD but
it's a different show and so someone in
the audience and I are having a little
conversation in the middle of doing the
bit and it turns out it's not like
heckler meanest but it's but it's
interaction and right you know so it's
advantage versus like an ad yeah you
ad-libbed around your métier I'd live a
little bit but but it's like yeah that's
everybody wants to know about what's
that what's it like when you get heckled
or what's it like when this happens and
mostly it doesn't happen that often
alright and most of the time it's not
mean they're not mean right well that's
that album that you have that's why I
did try to put there's a few of the mean
ones but there's I would say there's
more of the ones where I'm trying to
save it with funny in the situation yeah
yeah or your or your slow to anger
you're the guy was like look I don't
want to pull don't make me we're not
gonna draw I don't want to draw I don't
wanna oh God thank god that guy's inand
in a headlock in my brain somewhere he's
gone don't like him
what else is on this list need new
material it says that that's it it it it
it and talk about my anniversary it's
not really a problem but how many years
10-year anniversary I just went 13 I'm
very bad at UM planning events for event
for like anniversaries and stuff I don't
are you good at a gift-giving or any of
that well we were both sick so it was
pretty low key and I flew home from a
gig that day and so it was just left
let's we just made it through wait a
nice family dinner but I feel like with
the presence now i want to point with my
wife where it's just like you tell me
either go and get what you want and then
I you deserve a present if you want it
or tell me what it is I'll go get it but
I've had too many experiences of I'll
buy a present and I had to say to my
voice you go you don't even just get me
something so that you have something to
give me and I go well because if I do
that then you want the receipt and you
take it back so that doesn't feel good
that does i mean i know that i can't get
you things that you like and so me
making a special effort to go and get
you a present that then you have to make
the effort to take back it feels crappy
to me so why don't we take out the part
where i feel crappy and skip to the part
where you get what you want and it's my
fault you know we didn't even buy each
other anything for our 10-year we just
went and did something fun and then i
say two and then what my mother my
mother-in-law watched her kids overnight
and we actually slept in our house with
no kids there for the night and was oh
well that's perfect that's nice it's
what will you talk about gift-giving I
don't know have you ever had one of
these I i bought my wife i think i spent
more than i should have spent one year I
don't remember what anniversary it was
or if was her birthday but I bought her
a gift certificate for this yoga studio
and she never used it and then the place
went out of business and we just lost
two hundred and fifty bucks I was just
like yes
why did you not use got me kind of mad
because I kept saying you're gonna use
that she'll be like I'm gonna and then
they went out of business and then like
I'm a jerk for saying anything like he
told you it wasn't like it was at the
gap you know with some mom and pop yoga
studio yeah I don't know I don't know
what to tell you gift certificates
that's I just feel like you just give
him cash just give him cash just hand
them here's a hundred dollars you're
doing a great job here's our dollars one
last thing and then I'll let you get out
of here I know you have stuff to do but
this is the same subject just a piece of
it that I left out which was I think one
of the reasons why we had a great
anniversary and I didn't really have to
try to do it but it's amazing how if I
just do this I have a great time with my
wife which is asked a lot of questions
about her job and have her you know
really be engaged with me and learning
like and I've done it like three or four
days in a row now and I'm gonna sound
like such a shitty guy that I should
just do it every day it's amazing how
there's things that you know can make
your wife happy every day and you'll do
them for days in a row and then you'll
go back to not doing them again I don't
know if you have anything like that with
your wife what mine is just listen like
us my wife's studies Alzheimer's disease
I mean it's a pretty hot it's pretty
intellectual when she's explaining what
she did in a day it's not like she
wanted her eous about that my white my
wife's father's got alzheimers right now
but that's beside the point we're done
with the podcast at some other point
when we're just being friends you know
yeah we can have that conversation but I
definitely think here's the thing that I
say to about my wife when I come home
from being out of town on the road which
happens a lot the first thing my wife
wants to do she doesn't want to hear
what I've been up to or what happened to
me in some strange city where I may have
run into a famous person or had some
weird show or sold out or made our
mortgage or whatever she wants to tell
me when I first get home I need to be
quiet so she can tell me all the things
that
and at home with her and our daughter
and then sometimes we're out of time and
she doesn't have time to listen to me
until the next day or maybe never maybe
never maybe maybe it's just like you she
doesn't you know but I have a job where
I get to tell people all about what
happened to me so I'm okay with that
right and then when my wife goes out of
town if she takes once a year should go
to New York for a week and see some
shows and I go see your friends then
when she comes home she wants me to be
quiet so she can tell me about all the
things that she did while she was away
and she doesn't you know maybe when
she's done she has she wants hear about
what my daughter and I did while she was
gone but but but sometimes no she's not
interest in that she when she went after
we're separated she likes to tell me
what happened to her while we were apart
and that's just how she is and it's sort
of for a while it bugged me because it
seemed like it was super selfish but
then when I jokingly said here's how you
do you know this way you want it this
way when I'm gone and then you want it
this way when you're going and it's
always you want to talk about your thing
and she was like haha yeah that's how I
am it's so so I guess once you realize
that that they really want to tell you
about what's going on with them in their
day I guess the best thing to do is just
listen I I mean are my job is to get to
talk to audiences and tell them what's
going on with my day and and so I do get
that part of me satisfied through that
but it is a little frustrating sometimes
because yep but haven't you noticed that
if you do listen to your wife for a very
long amount of time about her day and
everything that you missed that when
she'll have what my wife does this I
don't know if your wife she'll come have
a completion part of that and then she's
really engaged in here and what I did it
takes a long time though with my wife
and if you're waiting if you're trying
to rope a doper you better you know just
get get on the ropes and keep your arms
up because she can go now do you are you
one of those comedians that struggles
with listening and caring about it when
she's explaining or is it no that's
that's the thing I've got a pretty high
threshold for boredom so I can listen to
all of it and just as I like to talk to
that's
other thing we both like to talk I guess
is the thing but no one she's talking I
can ask her questions sometimes I've
said to her you know like do you know
how I ask you questions about this and
then I say some you say something and
then I ask you a question that has to do
with what you just said to me like so
when I say something to you and then you
just say some non sequitur thing to me
about dinner that makes me feel like you
don't care what I'm telling you and so
it's okay if that's the case but that's
gonna be the reason that I don't tell
you anything from now on because I don't
think you care we've actually had to
have that conversation my wife and I I
know whose podcast is this that's what
you're thinking no no not at all I'm not
think I think we should have started
with this conversation is what I'm
thinking is this is more in the
wheelhouse of a fixing Joe I don't go
second guessing this has been a good
podcast I feel like this is a solid
effort I'm III don't know if you agree
with this but I almost think and it may
I was about to say can stand-up
comedians but I probably mean all guys
cuz mostly regular people listen to the
podcast I find that sink most single
guys that have trouble in relationships
are guys that have an inability to do
that they want to just talk but they
can't listen and they have trouble in a
relationship mine oil and comedians
forget it i mean we talk so much so if
you're that way I think you're going to
be [ __ ] in a marriage like thank God
my wife called me on it like i don't
know how i was in relationships before
they must have just had a really maybe
their lives were so crazy the girls i
dated before that i could be really
engaged easily because when they have
crazy [ __ ] in there crying it's easy to
really listen but when it's just day to
day this is what I did at my job I used
to struggle with it who imagine I you
know and then a phd's job you know is
like oh my god she's telling me about
but it's amazing how well I've been
taking adderall too i'm on a new drug
now it's like I'm turning into the
Bradley Cooper in that limit what do you
want you're all I take adderall too
for a DD that's probably helped me in
the conversations with her she can
explain all this complex stuffing and
you know literally it's a little easier
to listen yeah like today right now on
the podcast listeners because they know
I take adderall it wore off it were off
about two hours ago I'm adderall lists I
should so this whole conversation has
been without adderall yeah yeah I feel
like it's been ok could you tell could
you see what I'm not listening no I
can't but there's a little reflection on
your glasses so I can't really see your
eyes that well but you could tell
couldn't you tell if I was not engaged
or engaged well I'm talking and not
listening with the with these because
this isn't a real it's a conversation
but it's also a podcast so we're both
trying to kind of keep it keep it
rolling you know so so you know Joe it's
not that you're not listening it's that
we're both kind of listening and all
we're also trying to make sure like is
this a good enough thing to say or I
should be quiet it seems like he had
something good to say I'm gonna let him
say going now all right but anyway
ladies are complicated relationship
relationships are complicated it'sit's
these other people you get into business
with other people and it turns out that
they're completely different than you
and they have all that like hopefully
you like a lot of the same things but
there's a lot of things that they like
that you don't like and there's a lot of
things that you like that they don't
like and so when you're in a
relationship there's a lot of
compromising a part of your bigger part
of your when you're single you can do
whatever you want sort of all day long
and then once you're married there's a
big part of your life is like well I'm
not going to do what I want right now
because I've got a I'm gonna do what my
wife wants or I've got to do something
that all three of us kind of like to do
together right it's like you're on an
you're in it you're part of a team and
you know how does what makes this team
work the best okay rights listening to
when I listen to her and she comes home
as soon as she walks in i say what did
you do today how did it go and if i
remember what she said yesterday is huge
like if i remember that and then i go
wall had it what happened cuz you know
they leave you off it's like you're
watching a TV show she leaves you off at
the end of her job and now then
it continued all right and she'll get
very upset if I'm she's like she has to
re-explain she doesn't like it's like a
you're at a movie someone sitting next
to you is going what is it what's going
on and you're just like well they told
you what's going on like why are you not
watching who so yeah that's my life Jake
but um thanks for thanks for doing the
podcast again thanks for him down like
we we sort of wound it down here at the
end but I feel like that's okay it was a
pleasure it's great to see you Joe I'd
missed you was such a treat to hear that
too I was going to get to be talking to
you yeah I I have a gig that I want to
book you on we'll talk about that in
California that you could go do on a
Saturday that'll probably be like one of
those nice little gigs that you took we
talked about earlier that that's local
and nice people and on a saturday night
if you have one free okay yeah I'd love
to do that so why don't we can we talk
about that maybe tomorrow because yeah I
got a girl exam I don't we don't want to
put that in this podcast okay yeah what
do you want to plug what gig do you do
in this week or next week Oh what gig
I've got my little calendar here what am
i doing I'm going to UM zanies in
chicago by the 5th through the 7th of
november and i'm doing a gig in
milwaukee at the pabst theater on the
twenty-seventh that's the friday after
thanksgiving at milwaukee and then i'm
gonna be in hollywood improv i'm at 28
and I'm going to portland in
indianapolis and irvine before the other
that's all go to my website Jake this
calm and they can look at all that stuff
well thanks dude tell your daughter i
said hi and I was great having you again
yeah my pleasure alright dude we'll talk
tomorrow yes later alright see Jeff
there
as always are hanging up on skype that
was the great Jake Johansen i hope i
hope we were engaging i hope you were
able to follow the whole conversation
that's uh that's how it works when you
skype a podcast I hope it sounded good I
hope it was a you learned something from
that let's just get to my plugs one more
time right here at the end if you want
to donate to fixing Joe go to joe
Matarese com I told you at the beginning
i'm going to tell you again now you can
get four of my cds for twenty dollars
you get two of my cds for the twenty
dollar donation you get download sent to
you and you also get a pair of tweaked
audio earbuds my podcast sponsor they
throw that in you get those for the
twenty dollars for thirty dollars you
get three of my cds which I've done in
my illustrious comedy career and for
forty dollars you get four of my CDs all
four CDs the first one is called quiet
please the second one is called fixing
Joe the third one is called disconnected
and the fourth one which jake talked
about is called when a comedian attacks
that's the all heckler CD so donate
donate to 40 that would really help me
out and i'll send you the four cds and
you get to tweak the audio earbuds ok
follow me on twitter we got to get that
up to 10,000 so i can sell the special
at the joe Matarese and if you want to
come and see me live this week i will be
at the Laughing Skull in Atlanta Georgia
like Jake and I said we love this club
it's great small its intimate amazing
food in the vortex there come on out
Atlanta people October 22nd through the
25th I'll be there all the way Thursday
through Sunday flying home on Monday and
if you want to come and see me open for
Bill Baer that'll be on november six at
the wells fargo center in philadelphia
okay all right not sure where the gig is
on the 7th what's an
it is in all be in coatesville
Pennsylvania the day after I opened for
bar november seven okay i hope by me
trying to fix me I help you fix you a
little bit I love my wife I love my kids
and keep downloading the podcast tell
your friends okay have a great rest of
your week see you later